add sara paxton to celeb crushes list
hmm that's not a gravy so you guys vote
out of my facebook it was between this
movie and big miracle and you guys
picked this movie did you make the right
decision
stay tuned the innkeeper's is directed
by ty weston he's made some low-budget
horror films in the past largely
independent and a lot of them have been
really popular with certain people
however his films haven't really reached
a mass audience because they're
different they unique and they're
original to most audience members that's
a little weird you're dumb just kidding
about these two workers who work for an
end is going to be shutting down very
soon Sara Paxton and Pat Healy play
these two characters the guy runs a
paranormal website where he tries to
find proof of scary and weird things
that exist in the world and Sara
Paxton's character is just really
interested in that whole idea of
discovering things and finding things in
the whole mystery behind it and
hopefully being able to find proof of
some kind and we follow her on a very
strange night throughout this hotel as
she encounters and experiences very
strange things I like this movie and
I'll explain why because a lot of
audience members have had problems with
this movie and I completely understand
why if you go into this film expecting
it to be insidious expecting it to be
the woman in black you will be
disappointed because it's not this film
has a lot of character development and
when I say that I mean that some people
may be bored by that they may feel like
where's the scares we want more people
grabbing shoulders and loud music that
doesn't actually build any type of thing
we want more jump scares that leads me
to something I really liked about this
movie there really are no jump scares
I'm not saying the movie isn't
frightening at all I'm saying that the
composer for the film never once has a
loud boom for like something that jumps
out of you and it's nothing and you're
like ah there's probably one moment in
this film where I was like okay that's
cheap scare was involving a bird once
again flying out of someplace that
happens in like every horror movie for
some reason which means that he wanted
us to be more genuinely frightened by
the things we saw then forced to feel
that way by some musical score which I
like and admire now
talked about the character development I
really liked Sarah Paxson's character in
this movie I was attracted to her
physically but I was also attracted to a
strike two hoes are fabulous yeah if
you're watching this I apologize I
really like Sarah Paxton's character in
this movie I was attracted to her not
just because she's cute but because her
personality her character traits and the
way she portrayed them she was a really
well-written character and she seemed
like an actual person that's what the
things I liked about this movie it was a
well-written film the characters were
well fleshed out they had fun dialogue
with each other and it just went in
places you wouldn't normally expect I do
have a few problems with the movie
there's one sequence in the film that I
thought was very scary it ended up being
a dream and I was like a dream sequence
just no not dream sequence no bad dream
sequence rarely do I ever like dream
sequences except in the movie Inception
those dream sequences were awesome also
it really didn't scare me that much to
be honest there were some suspenseful
moments I don't really feel like this
movie is meant to be terrifying and
that's why I feel like people will go
this movie and be disappointed also I
didn't really like the ending of the
movie and I'm not gonna spoil it of
course but I just I just didn't really
feel it it just felt like a letdown to
me the film has problems but I admired
it for what it was I liked the fact that
they weren't trying to just do the
standard slasher pick and go different
directions it also is a very well shot
movie with really good tracking shots
and I like that about this movie I'm
interested in seeing what else mr. West
does with movies I'm gonna give the
innkeeper's a B so I'd like to know
what's your favorite independent
low-budget scary movie you know not this
some big thing and guess what
Halloween counts it does because that is
an independent movie the innkeeper's is
in select theaters right now available
on demand and for rental on iTunes if
you like this review you can subscribe
to my channel and get stuck mine eyes
Oh